Michael Smolkin: טוב, שלום לכולם. אני מקווה שאתם שומעים אותי והכל בסדר.
Michael Smolkin: טוב, כפי שאתם יודעים, אנחנו התחלנו סמסטר היום וזו הרצאה ראשונה בקורס בחשמל אנליטי.
Michael Smolkin: אז אני מניח שאולי יצטרפו עוד אנשים, אז אני אתחיל לאט. בעצם מדברים פורמליים, כן? אני מאוד מקווה שבהמשך, מתישהו אחרי פסח, אנחנו...
Michael Smolkin: נתכנס כבר בכיתה ולא נצטרך ללמוד מרחוק. עכשיו, אבל בינתיים כפי שאתם יודעים, זה הפורמט.
Michael Smolkin: אז נמשיך עד ההודעה החדשה לקיים את ההרצאות בזום.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, ככה, אני אתחיל ממדיניות, כן? של הקורס. אז עקרונית, רוב הציון מורכב מבחינה סופית, זה 90 אחוז.
Michael Smolkin: ו15 אחוז נוספים, שזה 5 אחוז מעבר ל100 אחוז כמובן, שזה בונוס, מבוסס על תרגילי הבית שאתם תקבלו מדי פעם.
Michael Smolkin: בתקווה כל שבוע. עכשיו, תרגילי בית, אין חובה להגיש הכל.
Michael Smolkin: חשוב להגיש, כדי לקבל את כל הניקוד חשוב להגיש 70 אחוז מסך כל התרגילים. עכשיו, אלא אם יש סיבה מוצדקת כמו כמובן מילואים או אשפוז,
Michael Smolkin: מחלה רצינית, אז במצב כזה אפשר לקבל פטור, כמובן להגיש בקשה או לפנות אליי או למתרגל ולקבל פטור.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, כמובן נסיבות
Michael Smolkin: פחות חשובות כמו, לא יודע, יום הולדת, חתונות, מחלה לא רצינית. זה לא כמובן, זו לא סיבה לקבל פטור או לקבל...
Michael Smolkin: למעשה אישור לא להגיש תרגיל, וזה נכנס ל30 אחוז האלה שאתם לא חייבים להגיש. כלומר, אם יש לכם איזשהו אירוע בתקווה נסיעה,
Michael Smolkin: לאן שהוא, לא יודע, חופש לקחתם, זה בסדר, אתם יכולים לעשות את זה, 30 אחוז, ה30 אחוז האלה שאתם לא חייבים להגיש בדיוק מתחשבים בנסיבות האלה.
Michael Smolkin: אז שוב פעם אני חוזר, 15 אחוז זה תרגילי בית. עכשיו, וחובה להגיש, כדי לקבל ציון מלא, חובה להגיש 70 אחוז. שוב פעם, אם מישהו בוחר לא להגיש בכלל,
Michael Smolkin: זה גם בסדר, הוא עדיין יכול לגשת לבחינה, אבל במצב כזה הציון שלו מתחיל מ90, זה הכל. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, מבחינת תרגילי בית, כמובן אני מאוד ממליץ לעשות אותם ברצינות. אולי חלק מכם ישיג פתרון, לא יודע, ייעזר בפתרון של חבר.
Michael Smolkin: אני כמובן שמח אם אתם משתפים פעולה, מדברים על זה, אבל חשוב ואני באמת מפציר בכם לעשות את התרגילים ברצינות.
Michael Smolkin: לחשוב עליהם במהלך הסמסטר, כי זה באמת מחזק את הידע שלכם ומכין אתכם לבחינה בצורה טובה.
Michael Smolkin: ולא לזלזל בזה, זה הכל. ושוב פעם, האחוזים האלה, 5 אחוז, זה באמת בונוס
Michael Smolkin: כדי שתרגישו בנוח לעשות טעות כאן ושם בבחינה ובכל אופן לקבל ציון טוב. אבל אני באמת מבקש להקדיש זמן, גם אם לא יודע, אייאיי פתר לכם תרגיל כזה או אחר,
Michael Smolkin: מבחינתי אתם מוזמנים להשתמש בכלים האלה, אפילו מומלץ, אבל חובה לעבור על זה ולהבין מה כתוב שם, כן? לא סתם...
Michael Smolkin: להגיש את זה בלי אפילו לחשוב על מה כתוב שם. זו באמת לא דרך מוצלחת ללמוד את החומר וכמובן מי ש...
Michael Smolkin: פחות מעוניין בחומר, אלא מעוניין בלעבור את הבחינה, זו גם לא הדרך האופטימלית לעשות בחינה באופן מוצלח. אז זה לגבי תרגילי בית והרכב הציון. עכשיו,
Michael Smolkin: שעות קבלה. עקרונית, יש לא מעט משתתפים בקורס ולכן אין שעה נוחה לאחוז ניכר של סטודנטים, כי לכל אחד יש לו משלו וכולי.
Michael Smolkin: לכן אנחנו נתחיל במתכונת הבאה. אין שעה מוגדרת. מי שרוצה לדבר איתי או בזום או בלהיפגש אישית,
Michael Smolkin: שולח לי אימייל ואנחנו נקבע את השעה הנוחה. גם אם יש לכם איזושהי קבוצה, אתם עובדים נגיד בקבוצה ואתם רוצים כקבוצה להיפגש, אז אחד הנציגים שישלח לי את האימייל,
Michael Smolkin: אנחנו נמצא זמן במהלך השבוע, זמן נוח לאותם אנשים ולי, ונדבר וניפגש. כי זו המתכונת גם ש...
Michael Smolkin: שהייתה בשנה שעברה והיא הייתה מוצלחת. כלומר, באמת אנשים שרצו להיפגש איתי, כולם נפגשו. אני לא חושב שהיה מישהו שפנה ולא נפגש איתי בסוף.
Michael Smolkin: גם בדרך כלל, הרבה פעמים יש ביקוש גדול, אגב אני רוצה לציין את זה, יש ביקוש גדול לפגישות מהסוג הזה לקראת הבחינה, שזה טבעי לחלוטין.
Michael Smolkin: אבל אני רוצה מיד, כבר עכשיו, להגיד לכם ששבוע לפני הבחינה, אני כמובן אשמח לעשות איזושהי פגישה, אבל לא תהיה היענות כזאת גורפת, כי פשוט
Michael Smolkin: המון אנשים פונים בשבוע האחרון וזה לא טוב. לכן, אם מישהו רוצה להתכונן, אני מבין שיש אילוצים לפעמים מבחינות אחרות.
Michael Smolkin: ולכן אני עדיין, אנחנו כן ניפגש גם בשבוע האחרון, אבל זה לא, לא מדובר באינסוף פגישות, אולי פגישה אחת או שתיים. אוקיי, לכן מי שמעוניין להיפגש,
Michael Smolkin: תחשבו על זה מראש לפני הבחינה ולא לדחות את זה ממש לרגע אחרון, כי זה קורה כל פעם ואני כבר עכשיו אומר, לא תהיה היענות טובה, כי באמת יש מלא אנשים שפונים, כולם רוצים להיפגש אפילו כמה פעמים,
Michael Smolkin: ואני פשוט לא מצליח, אני לא יכול לעשות יותר מדי פגישות. עכשיו, ככה, לגבי...
Michael Smolkin: אז דיברנו על שעת קבלה, לגבי ספרים שאני ממליץ, אז אולי אני אתחיל כבר לשתף ולכתוב. אז שנייה אחת.
Michael Smolkin: אז ככה, אני אכתוב עוד פעם, זה קורס מאוד קלאסי ויש המון ספרים ומעט מהם קראתי,
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? מתוך כל הספרות הענפה הזאת בנושא של חשמל אנליטי. אני אמליץ כמה ספרים שהם באמת קלאסיים, קנוניים ומאוד טובים.
Michael Smolkin: ואתם תבחרו, אוקיי? מה בעצם אתם רוצים לקרוא, ואני מאוד ממליץ לקרוא באמת את הספרים האלה, להיעזר בהם. עכשיו, הקורס עצמו,
Michael Smolkin: לא כולו, אבל הרוב המכריע מבוסס על ספר של לנדאו וליפשיץ, "'קלאסיקל סוריו פילדס'", זה קרח שני, יש סדרה של לנדאו ליפשיץ, סדרה של...
Michael Smolkin: כל מיני נושאים, עשרה ספרים בכל מיני נושאים. אז הקרח הראשון מוקדש למכניקה, מי שלמד מכניקה אנליטית,
Michael Smolkin: אני בטוח נתקל בספר של לנדאו וליפשיץ. קרח שני מוקדש ל... טוב,
Michael Smolkin: תורת שדות קלאסית. למה זה נקרא תורת שדות קלאסית ולא אלקטרודינמיקה? כי באותה תקופה, באותן שנים שהספר הזה נכתב, היו שתי תורות שדה קלאסיות יסודיות.
Michael Smolkin: זה תורת שדות, תורת שדות אחד זה אלקטרודינמיקה כמובן, ו...
Michael Smolkin: תורת שדות נוספת זה כבידה. עכשיו, אז הספר נקרא ''קלאסיקל סיוריל פילדס'' כי זה באמת מוקדש לשתי התורות הקלאסיות האלה.
Michael Smolkin: אז אנחנו נתמקד בחלק של אלקטרודינמיקה, אנחנו לא ניכנס לחלק של כבידה. אוקיי? אז הספרים, ספרים, אני כותב כאן, ספרים מומלצים.
Michael Smolkin: אז ככה, ספר אחד כמו שאמרתי זה של לנדאו, לנדאו וליפשיץ.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, זה קרח שני, זאת אומרת זה נקרא קלאסיקל סיוריו פילדס,
Michael Smolkin: אני כותב את זה באנגלית כי אני לא חושב שיש תרגום של הספר הזה לעברית.
Michael Smolkin: אז זה קלאסיקל סיוריו פילדס, ועוד פעם, זה סדרה של ספרים, אז זה קרח שתיים. זה קרח שני. אוקיי? טוב, זה לא בעיה, אתם יכולים כמובן לחפש את הספר הזה בגוגל.
Michael Smolkin: בספרייה, אני חושב שהספר הזה הוא די נגיש, תוכלו למצוא אותו. עכשיו,
Michael Smolkin: ספר נוסף שהוא גם כן ספר מעולה, אבל אני פחות אשתמש בו, אבל עוד פעם, זה ספר שאני גם כן נהניתי לקרוא בזמנו, ספר מעולה גם כן.
Michael Smolkin: ואני ממליץ עליו באותה מידה כמו על הספר של לנדאו וליפשיץ, זה ספר של ג'קסון. גי ג'קסון.
Michael Smolkin: והוא גם כן נקרא קלאסיקל אלקטרודינמיקס. זה קלאסיקל.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז רוב הנושאים שאנחנו נלמד, אתם תמצאו בשני הספרים האלה, ואני ממליץ עליהם מאוד.
Michael Smolkin: במיוחד על הספר הראשון של לנדאו וליפצקי, באמת אני אשתמש בו לעיתים תכופות. זאת אומרת, באמת הרבה מהדברים שקרו בהרצאה, אתם גם תמצאו בספר הזה.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, יש גם ספרים אחרים של גריפיס למשל, שהוא גם כן ספר מצוין.
Michael Smolkin: ואני גם ממליץ לכם להסתכל בו. עכשיו, מי שלא יאהב את הספרים האלה, יוכל לפנות אליי באופן אישי, אני אמליץ על ספרות נוספת.
Michael Smolkin: כי יש עוד ספרים שקראתי בנושא ואני גם אוהב אותם, אבל פחות אשתמש בהם.
Michael Smolkin: אבל אני משוכנע שכל אחד עם מאמץ מינימלי, אבל בכל זאת עם מאמץ.
Michael Smolkin: יוכל למצוא ספר שמתאים לו. ואני, לכל אחד, לכל אחד שרוצה להיות פיזיקאי, אני באמת מאוד ממליץ להיעזר בספר, לקרוא. עכשיו,
Michael Smolkin: מה עוד? עכשיו, לגבי רשימות,
Michael Smolkin: אני גם אעלה למודל בהמשך רשימות של הקורס, כלומר רשימות שיעזרו לכם, שכמובן קשורות לכל ה...
Michael Smolkin: נושאים שנדבר עליהם בהרצאה ואתם תוכלו להיעזר גם ברשימות האלה. יהיו רשימות באנגלית ורשימות וגם רשימות בעברית של איזה סטודנט
Michael Smolkin: מעבר שפשוט סיכם הרצאות בצורה מאוד יפה, ואני אעלה את הרשימות האלה בעברית גם למודל, זה מוקלט. מוקלט ואני חושב שזה מכיל
Michael Smolkin: עד כדי שינויים קטנים את כל הנושאים שנלמד בהרצאה.
Michael Smolkin: טוב, אז נראה לי זה הכל מבחינה טכנית על הקורס. אז לפני שאנחנו מתחילים, אם יש שאלות אתם מוזמנים לשאול כמובן.
Michael Smolkin: תשאלו בבקשה, אני אשמח לענות ואם אין שאלות אז אנחנו נתחיל כמובן ללמוד. בקטע לוגיסטי, האם אתה מתכוון לעשות הפסקה או שנעשה שיעור עצוב?
Michael Smolkin: אני חושב שאני יכול, כל אופציה מקובלת, אבל אני חושב שההפסקה אולי קצרה, אולי לא של רבע שעה, של עשר דקות, זה משהו טוב כי אני לא יודע אם...
Michael Smolkin: זה עניין אישי, אבל למשל אני לא, פחות אוהב להיות תקוע מול מסך לאורך...
Michael Smolkin: שעה וחצי או שעתיים רצופות להקשיב, לא תמיד זה טוב, כן? במיוחד שיש לכם כמה הרצאות, זה לא מדובר בהרצאה אחת ביום.
Michael Smolkin: אז יש כמה הרצאות, אז אולי הפסקה קצרה זה דווקא טוב. אז נעשה הפסקה של נגיד 10 דקות, אוקיי? ואם מישהו...
Michael Smolkin: ירצה דווקא רבע שעה ולא פחות מזה, הוא יוכל גם כן לכתוב לי את זה באופן אישי ואני אתקן את זה לרבע שעה, ואם אתם בצורה גורפת תבקשו ממני לא לעשות הפסקה, זה גם בסדר, אני יכול לא לעשות הפסקה.
Michael Smolkin: אבל צריך להתחיל ממשהו, אז אני מציע הרצאה של שלושת רבעי שעה, עשר דקות הפסקה ועוד שלושת רבעי שעה נוספים.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי. כבר יש כמה סטודנטים שהגיעו וכתבו שהפסקה קצרה זה דווקא מתאים להם, אז אני... הפסקה קצרה של 10 דקות, בסדר? עוד שאלות?
Michael Smolkin: טוב, אז אולי נתחיל את החומר.
Michael Smolkin: אז קודם כול אני רוצה לספר לכם על מה אנחנו בעצם הולכים ללמוד ולמה, כן? כי בסופו של דבר למדתם חשמל ומגנטיות,
Michael Smolkin: כמה פעמים בחיים שלהם, ושלכם, פעם ראשונה אולי בבית ספר.
Michael Smolkin: קורס מאוד בסיסי ויפה, בית ספרי, בתיכון. פעם נוספת כבר במהלך התואר, כן? כי בכל אופן כבר הגעתם לקורס הזה אחרי שסיימתם
Michael Smolkin: קורס בחשמל ומגנטיות בשנה א'. אז שמעתם כבר כמה פעמים, אפילו אם נסכם את כל הזמן שלמדתם, אז בערך לפחות שנה, מעל שנה אפילו,
Michael Smolkin: של הרצאות ותרגולים, והשאלה למה אנחנו שוב פעם עושים את זה. אז, אז...
Michael Smolkin: הסיבה היא פשוטה, היא מאוד דומה למה שקרה עם מכניקה. גם עם מכניקה היה אותו סיפור, נכון? למדתם את זה בבית ספר, או לפחות חלק מכם בבית ספר,
Michael Smolkin: באיזשהו קורס מבוא, ואחר כך המשכתם ולמדתם מכניקה בשנה א', בסמסטר ראשון, ואז הגעתם לקורס של חשמל, סליחה, של מכניקה אנליטית.
Michael Smolkin: אז מכניקה אנליטית זה היה משהו מיוחד, כן? שסיכם בעצם את כל המעמד שלכם וניסח את זה בצורה מאוד
Michael Smolkin: מופשטת ורחבה. למדתם בעצם גישה אנליטית חזקה מאוד שפותחה
Michael Smolkin: בזמנים של לגראנץ', המילטון, גישה או הבנה עמוקה של עקרונות של מכניקה.
Michael Smolkin: מין בסיס תיאורטי אנליטי רחב שסיכם את כל מה שלמדתם והרחיב את זה משמעותית. אז בעצם,
Michael Smolkin: החשמל האנליטי יש לו לקורס הזה מבחינתי, כן? יש את אותו תפקיד. הוא בעצם מסכם את מה שלמדתם בצורה מאוד רחבה ומופשטת.
Michael Smolkin: שמאוד דומה בעיניי, מאוד דומה למה שעשיתם במכניקה אנליטית, רק למערכת קצת שונה.
Michael Smolkin: במכניקה אנליטית למדתם מערכות עם מספר סופי של דרגות חופש, כי מדובר בחלקיקים
Michael Smolkin: כן נקודתיים או גוף צפי, לא משנה. יש מספר סופי של חלקיקים, מספר סופי של דרגות חופש, ובעצם פיתחתם את הפורמליזם הרחב הזה על תנועה.
Michael Smolkin: של גופים פיזיקליים, מספר סופי של דרגות חופש. במקרה של
Michael Smolkin: שדה כמו שדה חשמלי ושדה מגנטי, מדובר במספר אינסופי של דרגות חופש. יש לכם שדה בכל נקודה.
Michael Smolkin: זה רצף. אז כדי לציין את המצב של השדה, אתם בעצם צריכים אינסוף פרמטרים.
Michael Smolkin: פונקציה, כן? למשל שדה בהתחלה, ברגע זמן התחלתי, אז צריך לדעת פונקציה שלמה, לא רק מיקום של כמה חלקיקים במרחב כמו במכניקה, אלא ממש פונקציה.
Michael Smolkin: אז בעצם המטרה של הקורס היא מקבילה למה שהיה במכניקה אנליטית
Michael Smolkin: במכניקה, במקרה של קורס מכניקה אנליטית. אז אותו דבר כאן, רק למספר אינסופי של דרגות חופש.
Michael Smolkin: אז אנחנו גם כן נרצה לנסח את עקרון הפעולה לשדה, הרחבה של מה שכבר למדתם,
Michael Smolkin: אז עיקרון הפעולה המינימלי ייתן לכם את משוואות התנועה, ואת משוואות התנועה כבר ראיתם, כמו במקרה של מכניקה ראיתם משוואות ניוטון, אז כאן אתם תראו שעיקרון הפעולה ייתן לכם את משוואות מקסלו.
Michael Smolkin: אנחנו נרצה גם להבין את הסימטריות של הבעיה ומתוך עיקרון של הסימטריה לקבל גדלים שמורים, כמו שבמכניקה קיבלתם גדלים שמורים כמו אנרגיה, תנא,
Michael Smolkin: טנא זוויתי למערכת עם מספר סופי של דרגות חופש. נרצה לראות את זה, איך זה קורה במקרה של שדה. אז אנרגיה, טנא וטנא זוויתי,
Michael Smolkin: לפעמים אנחנו לא מספיקים לדבר על תן הזוויתי יותר מדי, אבל תן הזוויתי של שדה, כי המושגים האלה קיימים גם במקרה של שדה.
Michael Smolkin: אז בעצם הקורס של חשמל אנליטי מקביל למכניקה אנליטית, והתפקיד שלו הוא מקביל לתפקיד של מכניקה אנליטית במסגרת של מכניקה. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, אז זו בעצם המוטיבציה, אוקיי? זה הכל.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, למה אנחנו עושים את זה? כי בעצם העקרונות האלה שנכיר בקורס הזה, משתמשים בהם גם אחר כך בהמשך בפיזיקה יסודית,
Michael Smolkin: של חקר החלקיקים או אינטראקציות בין חלקיקים, כלומר כל ה... הייתי אומר, כל הפיזיקה היסודית היום מבוססת על העקרונות האלה.
Michael Smolkin: כי כפי שאתם יודעים או שמעתם, כן? לפחות, החלקיקים בטבע מתוארים על ידי שדה. למשל, במקרה של...
Michael Smolkin: מכניקה קוונטית, החלקית מתואר על ידי פונקציית גל, כן? אז אותו דבר, אחר כך כשעושים, מוסיפים למכניקת קוונטים עיקרון של יחסות, כלומר לוקחים מכניקה...
Michael Smolkin: יחסות פרטית, עיקרון של מכניקה קוונטית, משלבים ביחד, מקבלים משהו שנקרא תורת השדות. כלומר, תורת שדות קוונטית זה בדיוק שילוב של
Michael Smolkin: מכניקה קוונטית ויחסות פרטית. אז השילוב הזה, יש רק שילוב אחד בטבע, זה נקרא
Michael Smolkin: תורת שדות קוונטית. אז לכן כל העקרונות שנכיר היום, נכיר במהלך הקורס במסגרת תורת שדות קלאסית, משתמשים בהם אחר כך במסגרת
Michael Smolkin: של תורת צידות קוונטית, שזה הכלי המתמטי לתיאור של פיזיקה יסודית היום.
Michael Smolkin: בסדר? אז אם יש שאלות לגבי מוטיבציה או שאתם רוצים שאני אחדד משהו, בבקשה תשאלו אותי עכשיו, ואם לא, אנחנו כמובן
Michael Smolkin: נתחיל מהמוטיבציה הזאת ונתקדם כבר בחומר תכלס.
Michael Smolkin: טוב, אז בואו נראה, ממה אנחנו נתחיל תכלס? אז אנחנו נתחיל מתורת יחסות פרטית. עקרונית למדתם את זה כבר במכניקה,
Michael Smolkin: אז בשבוע, טוב, בשבועיים הראשונים מה שנעשה זה בעצם מצד אחד נחזור על המושגים שלמדתם כבר במכניקה,
Michael Smolkin: סליחה, אמרתי מכניקה קוונטית? לא, במכניקה רגילה, כן? רמתם תורת יחסות פרטית. אז נחזור על זה ונרחיב. אני חושב שרבים מכם ילמדו כל מיני דברים חדשים שעוד לא ראיתם על תורת יחסות פרטית.
Michael Smolkin: וזו המטרה שלנו ב...
Michael Smolkin: בשבועיים הקרובים, בסדר? בעצם שבוע, אולי קצת פחות, נראה איך אנחנו מתקדמים. פשוט לחזור על תורת יחסות פרטית ולהרחיב קצת את הידע שלכם.
Michael Smolkin: ממה ש... זאת אומרת מהידע שבעצם רכשתם במהלך הקורס הבסיסי במכניקה. עכשיו, אז בואו נתחיל. אז דבר ראשון, ממה מתחילים בעצם?
Michael Smolkin: טוב, שוב פעם, זה סוג של התחלה של פיזיקה. ממה מתחילים בפיזיקה? בפיזיקה אני חושב ההתחלה, למשל במכניקה, זה חוק ראשון, כן? חוק ראשון.
Michael Smolkin: ומה זה חוק ראשון, כן? ולמה בכלל צריך אותו? כי על פניו, מה הוא אומר? הוא אומר שהגוף שנמצא במנוחה,
Michael Smolkin: סליחה, גוף שנמצא במרחב ולא פועלים עליו כוחות, כלומר הוא נטול השפעה חיצונית, אז גוף שנמצא לבדו,
Michael Smolkin: הוא שומר על תנועתו, כלומר או שהוא נמצא במנוחה או שהוא נע בתנועה קצובה. נכון? זה בעצם החוק, חוק ראשון בצורה
Michael Smolkin: באחת הצורות או בצורה נאיבית אם אתם רוצים, אבל זה החוק. עכשיו, על פניו, אחרי שאתם מכירים חוק שני של ניוטון, אז נשאלת שאלה מה צריך חוק ראשון, כי חוק שני אומר מסה כפול תאוצה שווה לכוח, או הגדרה של כוח.
Michael Smolkin: ואז ברור שאם אין כוח אז מס הכחול תאוצה שווה לאפס, וטוב, מסה לא מתאפסת, כן? חלקיקים מסיביים, אז מסה לא מתאפסת אז תאוצה שווה לאפס, אם תאוצה שווה לאפס אז ברור...
Michael Smolkin: כל אחד יודע לפתור את המשוואה הדיפרנציאלית הזאת, מקבלים תנועה קצובה. מנוחה זה מקרה פרטי. אז על פניו נראה שחוק שני מכיל כבר את חוק ראשון,
Michael Smolkin: עדיין אנחנו ממשיכים לדבר חוק ראשון, חוק שני וכולי. אז הסיבה הלוגית למה חוק ראשון, אני מניח שדיברתם על זה, אני רק מזכיר לכם למה חוק ראשון הוא חשוב,
Michael Smolkin: זה בעצם בגלל הגדרה, כן? כי אתם כותבים, כשאתם כותבים כוח שווה למסה כפול תאוצה, מדברים שם וכותבים אחר כך קואורדינטות וכולי, אז אתם כותבים את זה איפה שאתם מניחים שהמשוואה הזאת מתקיימת,
Michael Smolkin: במרחב זמן מסוים, באולם מסוים, וצריך להגיד עליו משהו, אז חוק ראשון זה בעצם מגדיר לכם את הבמה הזאת, איפה שהכול מתרחש.
Michael Smolkin: איפה שאתם כותבים את המשוואות ואיפה שאתם עוקבים אחרי החלקיקים, המכנים. כלומר, יש מושג מרחב זמן שבו
Michael Smolkin: בכלל אנחנו כותבים את חוקי חוקרים וכותבים את חוקי פיזיקה. ואם יש כזה מושג כמו מרחב זמן, אז צריך להניח עליו משהו, להגיד מה התכונות שלו. אז...
Michael Smolkin: אז התכונות שאתם מתחילים זה בעצם החוק הראשון של ניוטון, ואנחנו לא נזכיר אותו כרגע כי הוא פחות חשוב לנו, אנחנו פשוט נתמקד במרחב זמן. אז מה התכונות שלו? קודם כול, התכונות שלו
Michael Smolkin: קודם כול, אנחנו אומרים שאפשר להגדיר במרחב זמן הזה מערכת אינרציאלית. אז כמו בחוק ראשון, זה בעצם הגדרה של מערכת אינרציאלית. זו מערכת מיוחדת, כן? שאם
Michael Smolkin: הגוף נמצא שם ללא גורמים חיצוניים, אז הוא ישמור על תנועתו. בכלל, זאת אומרת, אנחנו... זה מין אקסיומה שקיימת מערכת כזאת, כי אולי לא קיים כזה דבר בכלל. אז מרחב זמן שלנו...
Michael Smolkin: איפה שהכל קורה, יש לו את התכונה הזאת, שניתן להגדיר בו מערכת ייחוס מאונרציאלית,
Michael Smolkin: ואם במערכת זאת אין כוחות, אין כלום, אז הגוף נמצא שם במנוחה או שומר על תנועתו, תנועה קצובה. עכשיו, ברגע שהגדרתם את המערכת כזאת,
Michael Smolkin: אז יש, אתם מיד מגיעים למסקנה שיש למעשה אין סוף מערכות כאלה, כי כל מערכת אחרת שתנוע במהירות קצובה ביחס למערכת אוניברסלית גם תקיים את האקסיומה הזאת. ו...
Michael Smolkin: לכן החוק ראשון, הוא בעצם חוק ראשון של ניוטון, הוא בעצם הגדרה של מערכות אוניברסיטאיות, הקסיומטית, הגדרה קסיומטית כזאת, כן? קסיומה, שקיימות מערכות כאלה, אין סוף מערכות שנועדות
Michael Smolkin: במהירות קצובה אחת ביחס לשנייה, ואם אין שם שום דבר חוץ מגוף עצמו, אז הוא ישמור על תנועתו.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, אז מהן הנחות על המערכות האינרציאליות האלה? אני אזכיר לכם כי אנחנו...
Michael Smolkin: אני כבר לא אכתוב שיש את האקסיומה הזאת שקיימות מערכות אינרציאליות, סיימנו עם זה. דיברתם על זה במכניקה, אני רק אזכיר לכם מה התכונות הנוספות
Michael Smolkin: של מרחב זמן. אז התכונות הנוספות, אז תכונות של מרחב זמן. תכונות של מרחב זמן.
Michael Smolkin: אז דבר ראשון, אנחנו מניחים, דבר ראשון, אנחנו מניחים, אמרתי קיימות מערכות אונרציאליות. אז קיימות מערכות
Michael Smolkin: סליחה.
Michael Smolkin: אינרציאליות. אז אמרתי, אתם זוכרים מה זה מערכות אינרציאליות, שוב פעם, מערכות שנעות במהירות קבועה, אחת ביחס לשנייה, ושומרות על תנועה של הגוף אם אין כוחות.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, אז קיימות מערכות אינרציאליות. עכשיו, תכונה נוספת שבטח נתקלתם בה, זה הומוגניות. אנחנו מניחים הומוגניות של המערכות האלה. אז הומוגניות.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי, הומוגניות, מה אומרת הומוגניות? הומוגניות אומרת שאין נקודה מועדפת. בכל הנקודות במרחב זמן שלכם, חוקי הפיזיקה יראו אותו דבר.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? זה לא שיש, אתם עושים ניסוי במקום, לא יודע, בגבעת רם, רואים תכונה מסוימת,
Michael Smolkin: ואז אתם מחליטים להעביר את כל המעבדה לוויצמן, עושים שם ניסוי, ופתאום רואים שבאותם תנאים, הכל אותו דבר, אבל פתאום ההתנהגות היא שונה. אז פיזיקה היא אינווריאנטית להזזות.
Michael Smolkin: זו תכונה של מרחב זמן. לא משנה אם אנחנו נעשה, נפיל גוף מהגג היום או נפיל גוף מהגג
Michael Smolkin: מוחרתיים, נראה אותן תוצאות. אז יש סימטריה להזזות, הן בזמן והן במרחב. שוב פעם, זו הנחה. או אם אתם רוצים, אקסיומה.
Michael Smolkin: זה לא משהו שאפשר לדמיין אולם אחר או לא יודע, מערכות אחרות. אבל האקסיומה הזאת היא מיוחדת ולמה אנחנו שומרים עליה? כי בעצם זה מתאים למה שאנחנו רואים.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז לכן הומוגניות של המרחב. דרך אגב, כשעוברים ליחסות כללית, אז שם העניינים קצת מסתבכים, אבל לפיזיקה שאנחנו נלמד, ההנחות האלה מצוינות. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: אז יש הומוגניות של מרחב זמן. עכשיו, בנוסף, אנחנו מניחים איזוטרופיות של מרחב זמן, זה גם כן איזוטרופיות. אז מה איזוטרופיות אומרת?
Michael Smolkin: האיזוטרופיות אומרת שאין כיוון מועדף. כלומר, אם אתם תעשו, תסובבו את המעבדה שלכם, מקודם הזזנו את המעבדה ממקום למקום.
Michael Smolkin: במקביל אם אתם רוצים. עכשיו אפשר גם לסובב אותה, אז אם עשינו ניסוי, קיבלנו תוצאות, אחר כך סובבנו את כל המעבדה, חזרנו על הניסוי,
Ohad Amitzi: אנחנו נקבל אותן תוצאות. כן, בבקשה, מישהו רוצה לשאול? בבקשה. כן, אמרת שהאזוטרופיות היא למרחב הזמן, וקודם אמרנו שיש הומוגניות להזזה בזמן, אז יש גם...
Ohad Amitzi: לא, איזוטרופיות הכוונה במרחב, הומוגניות זה במרחב זמן. איזוטרופיות של מרחב. תודה. אוקיי? ההומוגניות זה הזזה בזמן ובמרחב, איזוטרופיות זה של המרחב.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? כי אני מסובב את המעבדה שלי במרחב כמובן. עכשיו, אז הסיבובים לא ישפיעו. אז שוב פעם, זו הנחה על...
Michael Smolkin: מרחב זמן ו...
Michael Smolkin: אקסיומה, על סמך האקסיומות האלה אנחנו אחר כך בונים את התיאוריה, וכמובן תיאוריה צריכה לתאר מציאות, כן? במתמטיקה אנחנו לא חייבים לתאר מציאות, אפשר ללמוד תיאוריה והיא לא קשורה למציאות.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, בפיזיקה אין מה לעשות, רק תורות שמתארות את הטבע בסוף שורדות. כל השאר זה מעניין, אבל פחות. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, אז אלה תכונות של מרחב זמן שאנחנו מניחים. אז יש מערכות אינרציאליות, חוק ראשון אם אתם רוצים, הומוגניות ואיזוטרופיות. מה עוד?
Michael Smolkin: מה עוד? עכשיו, בינתיים כל מה שאמרתי זה לא משנה אם אנחנו מדברים על
Michael Smolkin: פיזיקה של גלילאו, שתכף אני אזכיר לכם באופן מתמטי למה הכוונה, או פיזיקה של יחסות פרטית של איינשטיין.
Michael Smolkin: זה לא משנה, זה משהו אוניברסלי, על קיום של מערכות אוניברסליות, הומוגניות ואיזוטרופיות. זה לא קשור ליחסות כזאת או אחרת, זה פשוט אוניברסלי.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו יש עוד, כפי שאתם יודעים, ביחסות פרטית יש שתי אקסיומות, אז יש עוד אקסיומה אחת,
Michael Smolkin: שהיא משותפת גם ליחסות של גלילאו, לפני איינשטיין, וגם ליחסות של איינשטיין. ומהי האקסיומה הזאת? זה עיקרון היחסות.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? עיקרון היחסות. עכשיו, אז אלה תכונות של מרחב זמן. עכשיו, מתקיים עיקרון היחסות. מתקיים עיקרון היחסות.
Michael Smolkin: אז מה בעצם אומר עיקרון היחסות? עיקרון היחסות, אני אכתוב את זה, אכתוב אותו ואז אנחנו קצת נדון בו. אז משוות התנועה עם וריאנטיות תחת מעבר ממערכת אינרציאלית אחת למערכת אינרציאלית אחרת.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז משבועות התנועה,
Michael Smolkin: ושימו לב, כשאני כותב כאן משוואות התנועה, אני לא מגביל את עצמי למשוואות תנועה במכניקה. באופן כללי, כן? פיזיקה, כי פיזיקה זה...
Michael Smolkin: בעצם חוקים או תורה, זה בעצם לכתוב איזושהי משוואה דיפרנציאלית שמתארת תהליך.
Michael Smolkin: אז משוואה דיפרנציאלית זה בעצם משוואת התנועה, אוקיי? אז משוואות התנועה, אני כותב את זה, משוואות התנועה חייבות להיות אינווריאנטיות, אינווריאנטיות,
Michael Smolkin: ישיבות התנועה אינווריאנטיות תחת מעבר בין מערכות אינרציאליות.
Michael Smolkin: כלומר, חוקי הטבע נראים אותו דבר בכל מערכת ייחוס אוניברסלית.
Michael Smolkin: אותו, סליחה. אם אותו דבר,
Michael Smolkin: בכל מערכת אינרציאלית. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, כלומר יש שקילות בין מערכות אוניברסיטאיות, לא משנה איפה אתם, באיזה מערכת אוניברסיטאית אתם בוחרים כדי לעשות ניסוי.
Michael Smolkin: מישהו, לא יודע, עושה ניסוי על רציף, לא יודע, ניסוי של מפיל כדור, כן? ומסתכל איך הכדור נופל ארצה.
Michael Smolkin: ומישהו מחליט לעשות את אותו ניסוי ברכבת שנעה במהירות קבועה. מפיל כדור גם כן על רצפת הקרון. אז...
Michael Smolkin: זה שתי מערכות אינרציאליות נעות במהירות קצובה, אחת ביחס לשנייה,
Michael Smolkin: ואחד נייח את אחד נע, אבל החוק יראה אותו חוק. ומשוואה שתכתבו ברכבת נעה, או משוואה שתכתבו על רציף נייח, תהיה אותה משוואה. לא יהיה הבדל.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז אנחנו דורשים שמערכות אינרציאליות הן שקולות. אז זה עיקרון היחסות.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, כמובן, עכשיו נשאלת שאלה מרכזית. נגיד שניסחתי חוק מסוים במערכת אוניברסלית מסוימת, בחרתי, ניסחתי, לא יודע, עשיתי ניסויים, ניסחתי,
Michael Smolkin: חוקיות מסוימת, כתבתי משוואה דיפרנציאלית. עכשיו אני... אותה משוואה צריכה להתקיים במערכת דיפרנציאלית אחרת, אמרנו, בסדר, גם ברור. אבל איך...
Michael Smolkin: איך אני מקשר או איך בעצם, מה חוק המעבר? איך אני בודק שזה אותה משוואה? איך אני בודק שהמשוואה אינווריאנטית למעבר בין המערכות?
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? זאת אומרת, איך אני עושה את זה מתמטית? כלומר, מה החוק שאומר,
Michael Smolkin: קח את המשוואה שלך, תפעיל עליה כל מיני טרנספורמציות, כי עכשיו אנחנו מדברים על מתמטיקה, ותראה שהצורה שתקבל, צורה של החוק שתקבל במערכת חדשה, היא אותה צורה.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז כדי לעשות את זה אני צריך לדעת מהי הטרנספורמציה בין המערכות האוניברסליות השונות.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? הגדרנו את המערכות, זה פשוט מערכות שנועדות במהירות קצובה אחת ביחס לשנייה, אבל איך אני עובר ממערכת למערכת? כלומר, אם יש לי איזשהו אירוע, נקרא לזה אירוע, אירוע זה משהו קרה בזמן מסוים במקום מסוים.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? קואורדינטות פלוס זמן. אז איך אני מעביר את האירוע הזה למערכת אוניברסלית אחרת? מה החוק? אוקיי? אז עד עכשיו, לא עד עכשיו, באופן כללי התחלתם את פיזיקה,
Michael Smolkin: כשחוק המעבר היה טרנספורמציות גלילאו, נכון? זה מה שעשיתם. מה טרנספורמציות גלילאו אומרת? היא אומרת שהזמן הוא
Michael Smolkin: אבסולוטי, אותו דבר בכל המערכות, זה אחד. וב', יש קשר פשוט בין מיקום של אירוע במערכת אחת למיקום של אירוע במערכת אחרת, אני תכף אכתוב אותו. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: אז שוב פעם, הטרנספורמציות גלילאו זה חוק או חוקיות מתמטית מסוימת למעבר בין מערכות.
Michael Smolkin: אף אחד לא אמר שהחוקיות הזאת בלעדית, כלומר אין משהו אחר שאפשר לכתוב.
Michael Smolkin: עקרונית אפשר לכתוב גם דברים אחרים. עכשיו, אז קודם כול, נשאלת השאלה מה מיוחד בחוקיות של גלילאו, תכף אנחנו נכתוב את זה וניזכר. וב', נשאלת השאלה למה
Michael Smolkin: בחרנו בה, אוקיי? אז הדרך, אז יש כל מיני דרכים לעבור בין מערכות, כן? אפשר לכתוב כל מיני דברים מוזרים.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, אבל יש מעברים שהם מיוחדים. אז אחד מהם זה גלילאו, בואו ניזכר איך זה נראה. אז... אז טרנספורמציות גלילאו, כן? אז נכתוב שכדי לעבור
Michael Smolkin: כדי לעבור בין המערכות. יש לדעת את הקשר בין המאורעות בשתי המערכות.
Michael Smolkin: קשר אחד, טוב, טרנספורמציות גלילאו זה קשר שאנחנו הכרנו בעבר. אז טרנספורמציות גלילאו מספקות
Michael Smolkin: קשר כזה. אז בואו נראה איך נראית טרנספורמציה בלילה. אני מזכיר לכם, אז נגיד יש לכם שתי מערכות אינרציאליות, אני אקרא למערכת אחת אס,
Michael Smolkin: כן, סיסטם ומערכת אחרת, אסתר. אני חושב שאלה סימונים שאתם השתמשתם בהם. אז יש נגיד מאורה,
Michael Smolkin: מסוים, אני אסמן אותו בנקודה. אז למאורע הזה יש איזשהו רדיוס וקטור במערכת הסטאד, ארטק נקרא לזה, ויש גם רדיוס וקטור במערכת אס.
Michael Smolkin: נקרא לזה אר. אוקיי? ומערכת הסתג למשל, אני אניח שהיא נעה במהירות יו,
Michael Smolkin: ביחס למערכת אס, אוקיי? כך שנגיד בהתחלה, ברגע זמן טי שווה לאפס, הראשית של אסתר וראשית של אס התלכדו, ואז עבר זמן טי מסוים, הראשית זזה,
Michael Smolkin: בשיעור יו כפול טי, כי המהירות קצובה, אז יו כפול טי. זה המיקום החדש. ואז מתקיים קשר פשוט, זה מה שגלילאו סיפק לנו,
Michael Smolkin: ארטג שווה לאר פחות יו כפול טי. אוקיי? וקיטג שווה לקי.
Michael Smolkin: זה מה שגלילאו מספק לנו. ככה הוא אומר, זה הקשר בין מאורעות. זמן אבסולוטי וככה תיחשב את המיקום או קשר בין המיקומים בשתי המערכות.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, מה מיוחד בטרנספורמציה הזאת? הטרנספורמציה הזאת זה בעצם חלק מחבורת גלילאו. זה נקרא חבורת גלילאו. אז הטרנספורמציות, אני תכף אזכיר לך,
Michael Smolkin: טוב, אזכיר לאלה שמכירים ואספר לאלה שלא מכירים. אני אומר כבר עכשיו שלדעת, אין צורך לדעת תורת חבורות ברמה של
Michael Smolkin: קורס מתקדם. מספיק לדעת מושגים, מושג בסיסי, בסדר? של מה זה חבורה. מושג בסיסי, פשוט הגדרה, זה הכול. אז הטרנספורמציה הזאת, זה חבורה... הטרנספורמציה הזאת,
Michael Smolkin: שייכת לחבורת גלילאו.
Michael Smolkin: כי אנחנו כמובן נחליף את ה... עוד מעט נסביר גם למה אנחנו רוצים להחליף את זה, אבל נחליף את זה לחבורת לורנס. כן, טרנספורמציות לורנס. אז טרנספורמציות לורנס שהכרתם במסגרת של קורס במכניקה,
Michael Smolkin: זה חוק אחר איך לעבור בין מערכות. אוקיי? כמובן יש בו משהו מיוחד, אנחנו נדבר על זה. אבל גלילאו זה הדבר המתבקש בהתחלה, למה? שוב פעם, מטעמים
Michael Smolkin: מטעמים של ניסוי, כן? בניסוי שאנחנו עורכים ביום יום, אין סיבה לחשוב, כן, יש שאלה? בבקשה.
Michael Smolkin: מה חבורת גלילאו? תכף אני אחזור לזה, אני רק פשוט רוצה לחדד כאן עניין פיזיקלי ואחר כך נתחיל, נמשיך עם המתמטיקה המשעממת.
Michael Smolkin: אז הדבר הפיזיקלי, שוב, הסיבה שככה אני כתובה,
Michael Smolkin: הטרנספורמציה היא סיבה פרקטית, ניסוי, כן? ניסוי, כי בסופו של דבר ניסוי אומר לנו מה מתאים ומה לא, ותכף אנחנו נחדד את זה מאוד טוב בהמשך בהרצאה אחרי הפסקה.
Michael Smolkin: אבל עוד פעם, כי מבחינת גליליה ומבחינת ניסויים שאנחנו עושים אפילו היום ביום יום, אין סיבה לחשוב שזמן זה משהו...
Michael Smolkin: לא אבסולוטי, או בעצם הזמן לא נראה אותו דבר במערכות שונות. אז מבחינת ניסוי, הטרנספורמציה הזאת היא טובה. הקשר הזה הוא טוב. עכשיו,
Michael Smolkin: לפני שאנחנו יוצאים להפסקה, אני רק דקה אחת עוד אבזבז ואז נצא להפסקה. עכשיו, מה הכוונה, למה הטרנספורמציה הזאת?
Michael Smolkin: היא חלק מחבורה. כלומר, הטענה היא כזאת, שאם אתם תיקחו כל הטרנספורמציות, כל טרנספורמציות גלילאו האפשריות,
Michael Smolkin: ומה ההבדל בין טרנספורמציה אחת לשנייה? זה פשוט בפרמטר הזה יו, נכון? כל מה שצריך לשנות זה יו, כי זמן הוא אותו דבר, לא חשוב.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז כל מה ש... אז הטרנספורמציות שונות, נבדלות זו מזו ביו הזה, בבחירה של יו. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: אז לכן יש משפחה שלמה של טרנספורמציות שמאופיינות על ידי יו, פרמטר יו. לכל טרנספורמציה יש יו משלו. עכשיו, הטענה היא שאם ניקח את אין סוף הטרנספורמציות האלה,
Michael Smolkin: כל אחד עם יו אחר. אז ביחד הן יוצרות מבנה של חבורה. ואני אדבר על מה זה המבנה הזה, פשוט אזכיר, או לאלה שלא מכירים אני פשוט אגדיר.
Michael Smolkin: מה זה מבנה של חבורה, ונעשה את זה כבר אחרי הפסקה, בסדר? אז כרגע זה מספיק, שפשוט יש לנו אינסוף טרנספורמציות גלילאו שמאופיינות על ידי יוים שונים,
Michael Smolkin: וביחד, האינסוף הזה, הקבוצה הזאת, יוצרת, יש בה מבנה של חבורה. טוב, אז בואו נצא להפסקה של 10 דקות. עכשיו זה 12:46, אז ב12:56, בסדר?
Michael Smolkin: ניפגש ונמשיך עוד שלושת רבעי שעה. אוקיי? ואם למישהו יש שאלות, בבקשה תשאלו אותי עכשיו.
Michael Smolkin: טוב, אז אני גם יוצא להפסקה וחוזר.
Michael Smolkin: טוב, אז בואו נמשיך.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, אז אמרנו, הנה יש לפנינו את הקשר המפורסם של גלילאו בין שתי מערכות אוניברסליות, ואמרתי, בדרך אגב, שמדובר באוסף
Michael Smolkin: שיש לו מבנה של חבורה, אני אגדיר עכשיו למה הכוונה. אז אם אומרים שלאוסף מסוים יש מבנה של חבורה, אז קודם כול,
Michael Smolkin: אומרים, קודם כול, הכוונה היא שיש איזושהי פעולה, נקראת פעולה בינארית, פשוט לוקחים שני נציגים באוסף הזה, עושים ביניהם פעולה, ו...
Michael Smolkin: כלומר, פעולה מסוימת ומקבלים איבר אחר באוסף הזה, בקבוצה הזאת. אז במקרה של טרנספורמציה, הפעולה הזאת זה הרכבה של שתי טרנספורמציות. כלומר, כי אתם יכולים לעשות טרנספורמציות גלילאו אחד,
Michael Smolkin: לעבור לאסתר ואז לעשות טרנספורמציית גליליה או נוספת, או לעבור למערכת שלישית.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, הטענה היא שתחת הרכבה, כלומר אתם לוקחים שתי טרנספורמציות, עושים הרכבה והטרנספורמציה שאתם מקבלים, טרנספורמציה חדשה, היא גם כן שייכת לאוסף הזה. כלומר,
Michael Smolkin: יש סגירות. הכוונה היא שיש סגירות של האוסף תחת הפעולה הבינארית הזאת, במקרה הזה, הרכבה. חוץ מהסגירות, חוץ מזה שבחבורה חייבת להיות מוגדרת פעולה בינארית,
Michael Smolkin: בתחתיה האוסף, הקבוצה הזאת סגורה. חוץ מזה יש עוד שלושה דברים שצריכים להתקיים. קודם כל, באוסף חייב להיות איבר ניטרלי.
Michael Smolkin: או איבר יחידה, יש כל מיני שמות. מה הכוונה? הכוונה היא שאם אתם עושים, לוקחים את האיבר הזה ועושים פעולה בינארית עם כל איבר אחר בקבוצה,
Michael Smolkin: אז מקבלים בחזרה את אותו איבר שבחרתם, את האיבר הנוסף. אז אולי אני אכתוב את זה כך שזה יהיה מולכם. אז ההגדרה של חבורה זה פשוט הערה.
Michael Smolkin: כן, אז הגדרה של חבורה. אוקיי, אז אני שוב פעם, אחר כך אחרי ההרצאה,
Michael Smolkin: תפתחו ויקיפדיה או כל ספר ותבדקו מה ההגדרה המדויקת, המתמטית, אני מאוד, אני...
Michael Smolkin: מתמטיקאי, בתור מתמטיקאי אני די רשלן, אז אני יכול לעשות דברים לא מספיק מדויקים, ואני גם לא חושב שיש כזה צורך לדייק יותר מדי.
Michael Smolkin: לא, זה לא עריכת דין כאן. אז הגדרה של חבורה, אז קבוצה עם פעולה בינארית,
Michael Smolkin: או פעולת כפל לפעמים קוראים לזה, בינארית, כך שמתקיים. אז אחד, סגירות.
Michael Smolkin: סגירות, אז הכוונה לקחתם למשל, אני אעשה הכול למקרה של טרנספורמציית גלילאו, כי זה מה שחשוב לנו, אוקיי? אז כאן פעולה בינארית, הכוונה היא ל...
Michael Smolkin: הרכבה של שתי טרנספורמציות, אוקיי? אז אני אפילו אכתוב פעולה בינארית, אז במקרה שלנו, אני...
Michael Smolkin: אז אני אכתוב כאן הרכבה, אולי ככה, הרכבה, הרכבה, במקרה שלנו, אז אדום זה למקרה שלנו, אבל באופן כללי זה איזושהי פעולה, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: אז זה כך שמתקיים, סגירות. אז הכוונה היא לקחנו, בואו נסמן את זה בטי טאג, זה טרנספורמציות גלילאו שהגדרנו. אז אתם יכולים לקחת טי טאגיים, להרכיב עם טי טאג, עשיתם טרנספורמציות גלילאו אחד,
Michael Smolkin: כיתה, אחר כך אתם עושים טרנספורמציית גלילאו נוספת, כיתה ג', ועדיין הטרנספורמציה שקיבלתם היא שייכת, היא מאותה צורה כמו טרנספורמציית גלילאו טיפוסית.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז זה שייך לטרנספורמציות גלילאו. שייך לטרנספורמציות גלילאו. אוקיי? אז זה סגירות. עכשיו,
Michael Smolkin: בנוסף, קיים איבר ניטרלי. אז קיים איבר יחידה. אני אסמן אותו בספרות מתמטית, או אם אני אסמן אותו באי, אני אסמן אותו ב...
Michael Smolkin: איי, זהות, אוקיי? זהות כמו מטריצת יחידה, אוקיי? טרנספורמציות יחידה. אז כך שמה הכוונה? אתם לוקחים טי טאג,
Michael Smolkin: עם היחידה הזאת, ולא משנה אם היחידה מאיזה צד, האמת זה גם לא כל כך חשוב לכתוב את זה, שזה משני הצדדים. ומקבלים בחזרה תתאג.
Michael Smolkin: וזה נכון לכל טי טאג, אוקיי? עכשיו, במקרה שלנו, מהו איבר ניטרלי? זה טרנספורמציה גלילאוטריוויאלית. אר טאג שווה לאר, יו שווה לאפס, אוקיי? יו שווה לאפס, אז אר טאג שווה לאר, טי טאג שווה לטי.
Michael Smolkin: אז זה טרנספורמציית יחידה, תעשו הרכבה של הטרנספורמציה הזאת עם כל טרנספורמציית גלילאו, תקבלו את אותה טרנספורמציית גלילאו בחזרה. אוקיי? אז במקרה שלנו, ככה הוא מוגדר.
Michael Smolkin: אר טאג שווה לאר, סליחה.
Michael Smolkin: וקי טאג שווה לקי, אוקיי? זה הטרנספורמציה. אז קיים באמת איבר כזה. עכשיו, מה בנוסף? אז קיים איבר הופכי. לכל טרנספורמציה יש טרנספורמציה הופכית. אז קיים הופכי.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז הופכי אוהבים לסמן עם קי טאג מינוס 1, אוקיי? הופכי. מה הכוונה? קי טאג.
Michael Smolkin: הרכבה עם קי טאג מינוס 1 שווה לקי טאג מינוס 1 הרכבה עם קי שווה לאיבר יחידה. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: תכף אנחנו נראה, נעשה את התרגיל הזה, נעשה הרכבה של שתי טרנספורמציות, נראה שקיים גם... ברור, מה צריך לעשות? צריך לקחת את אותו טיטאגן במקום מינוס יו פלוס יו, נכון? ואז תקבלו את זה.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, דרישה נוספת, רביעית ואחרונה, זה נקרא אסוציאטיביות גם. אז אסוציאטיביות.
Michael Smolkin: אז דרישה נוספת זה אסוציאטיביות. הכוונה היא שאם יש לכם כמה הרכבות ברצף,
Michael Smolkin: אז לא משנה אם אתם עושים הרכבה של כיתה, גם כיתה ג' בהתחלה, ואחר כך אם כי שלושה תגים או אתם עושים בהתחלה הרכבה,
Michael Smolkin: של הטרנספורמציה עם שני טאגים ושלושה טאגים ואז עם כיתה, לא משנה. תחשבו על כפל למשל, אז בכפל אתם יכולים לעשות אותו בכל מיני דרכים, כן? הסדר לא כזה חשוב.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, אוקיי? עכשיו, אז אם ארבעת התכונות האלה מתקיימות, סגירות, יחידה, הופכי, אסוציאטיביות, זהו, אז המבנה הוא מבנה של חבורה. אז אתם יכולים בקלי קלות לבדוק שלמשל אם אתם לוקחים
Michael Smolkin: לא יודע, שלמים, מספרים שלמים, מספרים שלמים, ופעולה, הפעולה זה פשוט פעולת חיבור, אוקיי? אז תחת פעולת חיבור, מספרים שלמים זה חבורה.
Michael Smolkin: כי איבר יחידה שם זה אפס, כי אם תוסיפו אפס לכל איבר אחר זה פשוט לא משנה אותו. וההופכי זה פשוט אותו איבר עם סימן הופכי, זה הכל. עכשיו כאן,
Michael Smolkin: אז הטענה היא ש...
Michael Smolkin: כי טאג או כל הטרנספורמציות גלילאו ביחד, תחת פעולה של הרכבה, זה חבורה. אז בואו פשוט נבדוק סגירות וכל השאר זה די טריוויאלי.
Michael Smolkin: הרכבות, אתם יודעים שאם יש לכם כמה פונקציות ואתם פשוט עושים הרכבה של פונקציות, אז ברור שהסדר הוא לא חשוב, אז אסוציאטיבית זה די טריוויאלי.
Michael Smolkin: איבר יחידה אמרנו מה זה, זה פשוט אל תעשו שום טרנספורמציות גלילאו, ארטק שווה לארטי, טק שווה לטי, זה איבר יחידה. עכשיו בואו נראה רק סגירות, כי זה לא כל כך מסובך, אז בואו ניקח, נגדיר טי תגיים,
Michael Smolkin: נראה סגירות, ואז השם יהיה מוצדק. אז נגדיר כי תגיים להיות שווה ל... כמו שהגדרנו שם,
Michael Smolkin: בהתחלה, אבל עם יו אחר, בסדר? אז קי תגיים, ככה נגדיר. אר תגיים שווה לאר תג מינוס יו תג כפול טי.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? וטי תגיים, אוקיי, טי תג אפשר לכתוב, טי תגיים שווה לטי תג. אוקיי? לא משנה, כל הטים שווים. טי תגיים שווה לטי תג שווה לטי, כן? כי זו הטרנספורמציה. אז בואו נעשה הרכבה.
Michael Smolkin: אז בואו נעשה כי תגיים עם כי תג. אוקיי? אז איך זה נראה? טוב,
Michael Smolkin: כאן זה ברור שכי תגיים פשוט שווה לכי, כי כולם שווים, אין עם זה בעיה. עכשיו, אר תגיים, אני פשוט מציג במקום אר תג, אני מציב את הביטוי שיש לנו כאן.
Michael Smolkin: את הביטוי הזה. אני מציף במקום ארטג. אז מה אנחנו מקבלים? אנחנו מקבלים אר מינוס
Michael Smolkin: יו כפול טי ומינוס יו טאג כפול טי, כי טי טאג שווה לטי. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: בסדר? טוב, אני אכתוב את זה ככה, שיהיה מובן. זה לא משנה, בשורה השנייה. ואז אנחנו קיבלנו אר מינוס יו פלוס יו טאג כפול טי. אז חזרנו לאותה צורה.
Ori Rabani: בהגדרה של ט"ג התכוונת הר פחות י"ט ט"ג?
Michael Smolkin: איפה? כן, אבל... לא, אני אומר, אבל בהגדרה איפה שכתבת, כתבת ארטאג פחות.
Michael Smolkin: פחות יו טאג. זה לא צריך להיות אר פחות יו טאג? לא, אני פשוט, אני מגדיר עכשיו שוב פעם, אני רק משנה את יו, נכון? עברתי קודם כל מ...
Michael Smolkin: אר לאר טאג, נכון? אני עברתי מאר... זה להפעיל את אי טאג. לאר טאג. ואז אני מפעיל על אר טאג, אני מפעיל אר טאגיים. המעבר מהר לאר טאג,
Michael Smolkin: שנייה. המעבר מהר להר טאג מאופיין על ידי יו. ומעבר מהר טאג להר טאגאי מאופיין על ידי יו טאג.
Michael Smolkin: כן, אוקיי. בסדר? אז כל מה שחשוב לך זה בעצם מה אני שם, מה אני שם כאן, כן?
Michael Smolkin: אני יכולתי גם לכתוב את זה ככה, לזה אולי, זה מה שמפריע לך? יכולתי לכתוב את זה ככה, זה גם טרנספורמציית גלילאו. כי זה טרנספורמציית גלילאו עם יו אחרת, זה הכל. ככה זה בסדר?
איתי קימל: ואז במצב הזה, איך הייתה נראית ההרכבה? אז שוב פעם, ההרכבה, עוד פעם, המעבר מוגדר על ידי פרמטר אחד, יו. עכשיו השאלה על מה אני מפעיל את היו הזה, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: אז אני רוצה קודם כל עשיתי כי טאג, זה אומר שעברתי לארטאג, אוקיי, כי, ועברתי, הפעלתי יו, הפעלתי יו ועברתי לארטאג כי טאג, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו אני מפעיל יו טאג, כן, זה יו, זה הכל יו. אוקיי, אולי אני צריך לעשות את זה ככה. אני לוקח קי ואר, מפעיל יו,
Michael Smolkin: עובר לטי טאג, אר טאג, אוקיי? ועכשיו אני מפעיל יו טאג כדי לקבל טי טאגיים, אר טאגיים, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, למה ש... וההפעלה היא תמיד כזאת, כן? כמו שכתוב כאן. ההפעלה היא זה, אני פשוט לוקח את ה'ארוויטי' שנתת לי ומפעיל עליו את ה'יו' המתאים.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? עכשיו, אז הנה, כשאני מפעיל את היו פעם ראשונה, כן? אז אני לוקח טיטאג, איך הוא נראה טיטאג? טיטאג נראה כמו טי, כי זה אותו דבר.
Michael Smolkin: ואיך נראה ארטג? הוא נראה ככה, אר מינוס יו כפול טי, נכון? אוקיי? עכשיו אני לוקח את ה...
Michael Smolkin: את האר והטי החדשים, אוקיי? ומפעיל עליהם את יו תגיים, זה הפירוש של ההרכבה. קודם כל תפעיל טי תג, הנה הפעלתי, עכשיו תפעיל טי תגיים. זה בסדר? כן, תודה רבה.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז עכשיו איך אני מפעיל? אני מפעיל את זה כמו שכתוב כאן. אולי אני... כן, אני... עכשיו כדי שזה יהיה פחות נוהל, כן? סליחה, כי...
Michael Smolkin: כן, כי הנה התחלתי, ככה, זה פירוש של ההרכבה. התחלתי מטי אר,
Michael Smolkin: עברתי בעזרת יו לכיתה גרטאג חדש, שזה זה. אוקיי? ועכשיו אני עושה את אותה טרנספורמציה רק עם יו אחר. אז הנה אני... זה...
Michael Smolkin: מה שכתוב כאן זה האר החדש והטי החדש. וטוב, טי חדש הוא פשוט אותו דבר כמו טי ישן, זה לא משנה. זה הטי טאג.
Michael Smolkin: וזה הארטאג, שעליו הפעלתי טרנספורמציות בעזרת יוטאג. זה בסדר? אוקיי, אם יש מישהו מתנגד אז תגידו את זה עכשיו.
Michael Smolkin: ועכשיו פשוט איחדתי את שני הביטויים וקיבלתי ביטוי שבעצם אותו ביטוי כמו ב...
Michael Smolkin: תבנית של טרנספורמציות גלילאו, רק אם יו חדש, מהו היו החדש? זה יו פלוס יו תג. נכון? עכשיו, אנחנו יכולים לקרוא לזה, הסכום, אני יכול לקרוא לזה יו תגיים,
Michael Smolkin: ועכשיו אני רואה שבמקום להפעיל טי טאג, במקום להפעיל טי טאג ואחר כך טי טאגיים, אני יכול להפעיל טרנספורמציה חדשה, כן? פשוט טרנספורמציה אחת.
Michael Smolkin: עם יו חדש, יו תגיים ששווה פשוט ליו פלוס יו תג, אוקיי? אז זה אומר, זה מה שסגירות אומרת, כן? פשוט...
Michael Smolkin: הרכבה של שתי טרנספורמציות זה כמו טרנספורמציה אחת, רק הם יהיו אחרת, זה הכל. בסדר? לכן יש כאן סגירות. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו אני מכניס אלמנט אולי חדש, חדש ישן, אני לא יודע אם שמעתם את זה.
Michael Smolkin: כש... טוב, הוא ישן, כי שמעתם את זה במכניקה. כשאתם עושים איזושהי פעולה מסוימת,
Michael Smolkin: אנחנו כרגע מדברים על משוואות התנועה, אבל בסדר, ברמה של פעולה אותו דבר. אתם עושים איזושהי טרנספורמציה או משהו, ומשוואות התנועה או חוק חוקי, ככה קראנו לזה,
Michael Smolkin: חוקי טבע, משוואות תנועה זה חוקי טבע. ומשוואות תנועה לא משתנות. אז איך אתם קוראים לטרנספורמציה כזאת? יש לה שם. סימטריה. סימטריה, נכון, סימטריה. אז לכן,
Michael Smolkin: הטרנספורמציות גלילאו, ועכשיו אני אגיד אולי משהו שלא אמרו לכם מקודם, אבל כל סימטריה
Michael Smolkin: בטבע או ברמה של משוואות, לא משנה מה, יש לה מבנה של חבורה. לכל סימטריה יש מבנה של חבורה. כלומר, יש סימטריה, פעולת סימטריה טריוויאלית, זה יחידה. אוקיי? זה פשוט לא עושה כלום.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? פעולה טריוויאלית. יש לכל פעולת סימטריה, יש פעולת סימטריה הפוכה, שפשוט מחזירה אתכם לאותו מצב, אוקיי? והסדר שבו אתם עושים את פעולות הסימטריה הוא לא חשוב.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? כלומר, הרכבה לא חשובה. כמובן, אם אתם הופכים, זה לא בהכרח קומוטטיבי, כן? אבל אם אתם... הכוונה היא שלא חשוב הסדר הזה, כן? שכאן,
Michael Smolkin: איזה הרכבה אתם עושים קודם, זה לא משנה. אוקיי? אז לכן, לכל סימטריה, באופן כללי, יש מבנה של חבורה. אוקיי? כל סימטריה מאופיינת על ידי מבנה של חבורה.
Michael Smolkin: זו סתם הערה של דרך אגב. אז לכן אפשר לנסח את זה ככה, שמשוואות התנועה
Michael Smolkin: אינווריאנטיות למעבר בין מערכות אינרציאליות שונות, זה כמו להגיד שמשוות התנועה הן סימטריות, סימטריות, או יש סימטריה של חוקים תחת
Michael Smolkin: אוסף של פעולות מסוימות. ובמקרה הספציפי הזה, האוסף נקרא טרנספורמציות גלילאו. אז חוקי טבע אינווריאנטיים או סימטריים לטרנספורמציות
Michael Smolkin: גלילאו. זה מה שבעצם כתבנו כאן. עכשיו השאלה אם זה נכון בכלל. האם חוקי טבע, בדרך כלל אתם כמובן מניחים משהו, אמרתי שטרנספורמציות גלילאו זה הנחה.
Michael Smolkin: הנחה שמתבקשת מניסויים שנעשו באותה תקופה. אוקיי? עכשיו השאלה אם ההנחה הזאת תקיפה. אז בסדר, לניסויים ביום יום זה תקף. עכשיו, באופן כללי,
Michael Smolkin: זה לא כל כך תקף. ואני רוצה להביא לכם דוגמה מאוד קונקרטית של חוק בטבע שאתם כבר מכירים, שהוא לא אינווריאנטי.
Michael Smolkin: לטרנספורמציות גלילאו, בסדר? כלומר, אני רוצה לשכנע אתכם שהמשוואות מקסוול שאתם מכירים, המשוואה הכי פשוטה, בסדר? שהיא לא תהיה אינווריאנטית לטרנספורמציות גלילאו.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? עכשיו, מה זה אומר בעצם?
Michael Smolkin: מה זה אומר? הנה, אמרנו, מצד אחד יש את טרנספורמציות גלילאו, מצד שני יש חוק טבע שגילינו במעבדה, משרות מקסו, זה משהו שיש לו...
Michael Smolkin: טוב, יש למשעות מסו, יש אינסוף הוכחות, כן? ברמה של מעבדה, או במילים אחרות, זה באמת חוק. עכשיו,
Michael Smolkin: כמובן יש חוקים יותר מוכללים, אבל משוואות מקסימום זה נכון. ואז נשאלת השאלה מה לא בסדר, כן? אז מצד אחד יש טרנספורמציות גיליון, מצד שני יש חוק טבע, כן? שמתקיים.
Michael Smolkin: והוא לא אינווריאנטי לטרנספורמציות האלה. קודם כול, בואו נקפוץ לסוף, כי את זה נראה. נגיד שהראינו שמשוואת מקסלו לא פרנסיסטנטיות לטרנספורמציות בלילא. אז מה מתבקש מכאן?
Michael Smolkin: שאלה מה יותר יסודי מבחינתנו. אז אני חושב שמשבועות מקסימום, כן? אז למצוא מספורמציה אחרת. אה?
Michael Smolkin: למצוא טרנספורמציה אחרת. בדיוק. אז אני חושב שבמצב כזה, המסקנה המיידית היא שטרנספורמציות גלילאו זה לא באמת טרנספורמציה טובה למעבר בין מערכות אינרציאליות.
Michael Smolkin: כי אני בודק את חוק מקסוול במערכות אינרציאליות שונות, אני רואה שזה אותו חוק, כן? אז הוא אינווריאנטי. אבל איכשהו כשאני מנסה לבדוק את האינווריאנטיות שלו תחת הנחה שזה המעבר,
Michael Smolkin: בין המערכות ופתאום משהו לא עובד. אז המסקנה היא שהמעבר שבעצם קבענו, או גלילאו קבע, הוא לא מתאים, הוא לא נכון.
Michael Smolkin: כלומר, יש טרנספורמציה אבל היא אחרת. אוקיי? אז בואו נראה את זה. כלומר, טענתי כאן טענה שבעצם חוקי טבע,
Michael Smolkin: או משוואת מצו לא אינווריאנטית לטרנספורמציות גליל, עכשיו אני רוצה להראות לכם שזה נכון. אוקיי, קודם כל,
Michael Smolkin: אני אתחיל ממשהו חיובי. אז קודם כול, בואו נראה שטרנספורמציות גלילאו משמרות את הצורה של משוואות ניוטון. אוקיי? קודם נתחיל מזה. אז משוואות ניוטון, טוב.
Michael Smolkin: או חוק שני של ניוטון, משוואות ניוטון, אינווריאנטיות תחת טרנספורמציות גלילאון.
Michael Smolkin: בואו נראה, אז איך נראות משורתנות? אני אקח צורה פשוטה, למשל, אם יש לנו חלקיק בעל מסה אם והוא מבצע תנועה, אז הנה זה מסה כפול התאוצה, כתבתי כאן גיב הריבוע, סליחה.
Michael Smolkin: היא בריבוע, נגזרת שנייה של מיקום, תאוצה, שווה לכוח, ונגיד שהכוח נגזר מפוטנציאל, אז הנה, יש לנו, זאת משוואת ניוטון. עכשיו,
Michael Smolkin: טוב, אז אגף שמאל, אם אני עושה טרנספורמציות גלילאו, טוב, אני אקח אותה אליי עכשיו. הנה, זאת טרנספורמציות גלילאו.
Michael Smolkin: מולינו, זה החוק.
Michael Smolkin: בואו נראה. קודם כול, טי שווה לטי טאב, אז לכן לא משנה אם אני כותב נגזרת לפי טי או נגזרת לפי טי טאב, כי זה שווה, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: אז אין לי בעיה להחליף די קי בריבוע בדי קי טאג בריבוע. עכשיו, מה לגבי אר? האם אני יכול להחליף את אר באר טאג? אני חושב שכן, כי טרנספורמציית גליליה היא ליניארית בזמן, נכון?
Michael Smolkin: אז אם אני לוקח נגזרת שנייה, נגזרת שנייה בשני אגפים, אז מכאן, מהמבנה של טרנספורמציות גלילאו, אם אני אקח נגזרת שנייה של ארטר,
Michael Smolkin: אם אני אקח נגזרת ראשונה לפי טי טאג, אז זה כמו די אר לטי טי מינוס יו. זה חוק חיבור המהירויות, כן?
Michael Smolkin: בצד שמאל אני גוזר לפי טייטאג, שוב פעם, לכתוב טייטאג או טי, זה לא משנה, הם שווים. עכשיו, אבל אם אני עכשיו אקח נגזרת נוספת, אז אני כבר אקבל שוויון.
Michael Smolkin: זו בעצם הטענה, כאן הפעלתי נגזרת, שהיא אותו דבר כמו נגזרת לפי כיתה, ואחר כך הפעלתי נגזרת נוספת.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי, אז עוד פעם, אין כאן משהו חדש. השורה הראשונה, השורה הזאת, זה פשוט חוק חיבור המהירויות.
Michael Smolkin: ושורה שנייה אומרת פשוט שהתאוצות במערכות אונרציאליות, תאוצה זה משהו שלא משתנה ממערכת אונרציאלית, במעבר בין מערכות אונרציאליות, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, אז לכן אגף שמאל, אני פשוט יכול לכתוב שזה שווה לאם, די בריבוע אר טאג, לדי קי טאג בריבוע. כלומר, אגף שמאל באמת נראה אותו דבר בשתי המערכות, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: מה לגבי אגף ימין? באגף ימין אני גוזר לפי אר, כי זה גרדיאנט של פוטנציאל, אני גוזר לפי אר. עכשיו, לגזור לפי אר זה לא אותו דבר כמו לגזור לפי ארטר, אבל יש קשר בין אר לארטר, אז אני יכול להשתמש ב...
Michael Smolkin: שרשרת, כן, כלל שרשרת בגזירה. אז אני יכול לכתוב את זה ככה,
Michael Smolkin: נגיד שאני מחשב די לדי אקס של וי, של אר, של טי. זה אותו דבר כמו די לדי אקס טאג, נכון? של וי.
Michael Smolkin: ואז לגזור את אקס טאג לפי אקס, נכון? זה לא הכל, כמובן יש גם גזרות לפי ווי טאג, ווי טאג לפי אקס, וזה טאג, וזה טאג לפי אקס, נכון?
Michael Smolkin: כלל שרשרת, למשל אני מסתכל על הרכיב אקס של הגרדיאנט, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: פלוס די וואי טאג לפי אקס, די לדי וואי טאג של וי, של אר, של טי. ואם יש זד, אז די זד טאג לדי אקס, די לדי זד טאג
Michael Smolkin: של די, של אר ודי. נכון? כל שרשרת הפעלתי. כי אר זה פונקציה של ארטרקה. עכשיו, כאן אני מחליף את אר
Michael Smolkin: לאר כפונקציה של ארתר וטי כפונקציה של טיטר. בסדר? אבל זה שווה.
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, אבל מהקשר בין ארטג לאר, מהקשר בין ארטג לאר, למשל, ווייטאג שווה לווי מינוס יוטי, אז ווייטאג לא שווה, לא תלוי באקס בכלל.
Michael Smolkin: כלומר, מהקשר המפורש בין ארטג לאר, אני יודע שאלה שווים לאפס, כי פשוט דיזטג לדיאקס שווה לאפס.
Michael Smolkin: כי זה תג שווה לז מינוס יו טי, אז אין שם זכר של אקס. אוקיי? אז לכן אלה מתבטלים. ודי אקס תג לדי אקס, פשוט תגזרו את זה.
Michael Smolkin: תכתבו למה שווה אקסטר. אקסטר שווה לאקס מינוס יו אקס כפול טי. ואז אם אתם גוזרים דיאקסטר לדיאקס, פשוט תקבלו 1.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז לכן זה שווה ל1, ולכן אנחנו מגיעים למסקנה שדי וי לדי אפס שווה לדי וי לדי אפס סתיו.
Michael Smolkin: וכנ"ל אפשר לעשות את זה לכל שאר הרכיבים.
Michael Smolkin: לוואי וזד, ולכן המסקנה הכללית שפשוט לגזור את... לקחת גרדיאנט של פוטנציאל לפי קואורדינטות אקס ווייזד, זה כמו לקחת את הגרדיאנט של פוטנציאל לפי קואורדינטות אקס טאג ווייטאג זה טאג.
Michael Smolkin: עבור טרנספורמציית גלילי האופקוס, בוודאי. באופן כללי זה לא נכון. אז לכן מקבלים מינוס גרדיאנט טאג, אוקיי? כלומר, לחשב גרדיאנט לפי אקס טאג ווייטאג, זה טאג של וי.
Michael Smolkin: וזה אומר שמשוואת ניוטון אינווריאנטית לטרנספורמציות גלילאו. באמת, אם עושים את המעבר הזה, הכל טוב. אוקיי? אוקיי. עכשיו,
Michael Smolkin: בואו נראה שזה לא המצב אם אנחנו מוסיפים כאן, אם במקום לחקור משוואת ניוטון בנוכחות פוטנציאל, נחקור משוואת ניוטון בנוכחות של שדה חשמלי ושדה מרנטי, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: כי כאן הראיתי, הנחתי שהחלקית נעה בפוטנציאל, כוח יש בצורה מאוד מסוימת, ואז הראינו שמשוואות ניוטון אינווריאנטיות. עכשיו אני,
Michael Smolkin: חותר לכיוון קצת יותר מעניין. אני רוצה לחקור תנועה של חלקית בנוכחות של שדה אלקטרומגנטי, שדה חשמלי ושדה מגנטי כפי שאתם הכרתם. ועכשיו,
Michael Smolkin: אני יודע שהשדה משפיע על חלקיק, אם הוא טעון, והחלקיק הטעון משפיע על שדה כי הוא מייצר שדה, נכון?
Michael Smolkin: ולכן משוואה דינמית כוללת, מכילה בתוכה גם משוואת חוק ניוטון לתנועה של חלקית, וגם משוואות מקסוול לשינויים בשדה. מסכימים?
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי. אז בנוכחות, לעומת זאת, בנוכחות אי ובי,
Michael Smolkin: שדה אלקטרומגנטי, אוקיי? זה שדה אלקטרומגנטי. חוק שני, הנתון על ידי
Michael Smolkin: אז בואו נכתוב חוק שני עכשיו, זה אם כפול נגזרת שנייה,
Michael Smolkin: לפי זמן שווה ל... עכשיו אני רוצה לכתוב חוק שני, כשיש שדה חשמלי ושדה מגנטי, אז יש כוח חשמלי, כוח חשמלי ככה הוא נראה, נכון? וכוח לורנס, איך הוא נראה?
Michael Smolkin: ככה הוא נראה. אני יודע שאתם אולי למדתם את הקורס ביחידות אם.קי.אס, באם.קי.אס אין שיא, אין בכוח לא רק שיא.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? זה פשוט קיו ויקרוס בי, נכון? ככה למדתם. אנחנו נעבוד ביחידות סי.ג'י.אס, כי כשמדברים על אפקטים יחסותיים, יחידות סי.ג'י.אס הרבה יותר נוחים.
Michael Smolkin: בסדר? זה הרבה יותר נוח לעבוד בסי.ג'י.אס, זה בסי.ג'י.אס. אני משתמש עכשיו בסי.ג'י.אס. סנטימטר גרם שנייה, לא אם.קי.אס. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: אז לכן יש כאן את אחד חלקי שיא. זה הכל, זה פשוט העניין, הוא לא... כרגע לדיון שלנו זה בכלל לא חשוב, אבל...
Michael Smolkin: שוב, אני כבר ברגע זה אומר לכם שאנחנו נעבוד ביחידות סי ג'יאס בקורס הזה.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? עכשיו אנחנו רוצים, זה חוק, חוק שנקבע לפי ניסויים. שוב פעם, אנחנו יודעים שזה נכון.
Michael Smolkin: וגלילאו אומר לנו שאם אנחנו רוצים להעביר את החוק הזה בין מערכות אינרציאליות שונות, צריך להשתמש במעבר הספציפי הזה.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? זה מה שגלילאו אומר לנו. אז עכשיו בואו נראה, נדרוש, פשוט נניח, כן? שהחוק הזה הוא אוניבריאנטי תחת טרנספורמציות גלילאו, מתוך ההנחה הזאת אנחנו
Michael Smolkin: בדרישה הזאת נקבל חוק טרנספורמציה לשדות, אוקיי? בין המערכות השונות, ואז נראה שזה לא קונסיסטנטי עם משוואות מקסלוב. בסדר? אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: אז אנחנו כבר יודעים שצד שמאל, צד שמאל, כי צד שמאל נראה אותו דבר בחוק מוטון, אין כפול תאוצה. ולפי טרנספורמציות גלילאו, הצד שמאל לא משתנה, נראה אותו דבר.
Michael Smolkin: אז לכן, אם אינפורמציות גלילאו משמרות את החוק, זה אומר שגם צד ימין חייב להיות אותו דבר. מסכימים?
Michael Smolkin: אם מישהו לא מסכים, שיגיד עכשיו. אז בהנחה שעיקרון היחסות
Michael Smolkin: מתקיים תחת טרנספורמציות גלילאו, נקבל
Michael Smolkin: אגף שמאל אינווריאנטי, כבר בדקנו, כן עשינו את זה, הנה כאן עשינו. הראינו שזה אותו דבר אגף שמאל, לכן אגף ימין הוא אינווריאנטי, אז אנחנו נקבל במערכת תג אנחנו נקבל קיו,
Michael Smolkin: אי טאג פלוס קיו חלקי סי כפול וי טאג קרוס בי טאג
Michael Smolkin: חייב להיות שווה לקיו כפול אי פלוס קיו חלקי סי וי קרוס בי. שוב, כאן השתמשתי בעובדה ש...
Michael Smolkin: השדות אני לא יודע, השדות גם כן יש איזשהו חוק טרנספורמציה, אני לא יודע מה החוק טרנספורמציה של השדות, אבל זה לא חייב להיות אותו דבר.
Michael Smolkin: גם המהירות, אנחנו כבר יודעים שהמהירות של חלקיק היא לא אותו דבר בשתי המערכות. קיבלנו את זה במפורש כאן. איפה זה כאן?
Michael Smolkin: זה חוק הטרנספורמציה של מהירויות, אז מהירויות לא אותו דבר, שדות לא אותו דבר, אז לקחתי את זה בחשבון, אבל מכיוון שצד שמאל של המשוואה הוא אינווריאנטי, גם צד ימין צריך להיראות אותו דבר.
Michael Smolkin: מסכימים? אם עיקרון היחסות מתקיים, כאן כמובן אני מניח שעיקרון היחסות מתקיים ו...
Michael Smolkin: וטרנספורמציות גלילאו, אלה הטרנספורמציות הנכונות לעשות את זה. אז לכן זו המסקנה. עכשיו, אנחנו יודעים מה הקשר בין וי לויתר. אז אני...
Michael Smolkin: מציב כאן וי טאג שווה לוי מינוס יו, זה הקשר. זה שוב פעם, זה לפי גלילאו, זה גלילאו אמר לנו. הנה זה כאן.
Michael Smolkin: וי טאג שווה לוי מינוס יו. אז אני מציב את זה ומקבל את הביטוי הבא, קיו כפול אי טאג פלוס
Michael Smolkin: קיו חלקי סי, וי קרוס, סליחה.
Michael Smolkin: וי קרוס, אני אעביר איברים אגפים ואכנס אותם, בסדר? ככה שזה יהיה יותר יפה. שווה לי.
Michael Smolkin: קיו כפול אי פלוס קיו חלקי סי
Michael Smolkin: יו קרוס ביטאג. אה, כן. נכון? תסתכלו על המשוואה.
Michael Smolkin: אגב, כי אם אני יכול לזרוק, בואו נזרוק את זה.
Michael Smolkin: מסכימים?
Michael Smolkin: פשוט העברתי אגף, כן? שמתי את האיברים שתלויים בוי ביחד.
Michael Smolkin: אם מישהו מתנגד אז שיגיד בקיו אם אני צמצמתי. תודה, אני רואה שכבר חלק
Michael Smolkin: מסטודנטים ראו שהכול בסדר, פשוט הצבתי ויטאג, העברתי אגף, איברים שתלויים בוי, שמתי ביחד וזהו. בסדר? עכשיו, בואו נסתכל על המשוואה הזאת, יש כאן כבר משהו מעניין.
Michael Smolkin: צד שמאל כאן, תלוי מפורשות, האיבר הזה תלוי מפורשות בוי, במהירות של החלקיק, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: אין בשום מקום אחר תלות במהירות של החלקיק. תסתכלו למשל, מה זה איתק? זה סך הכל שדה חיצוני, כן? שנוצר על ידי מקורות חיצוניים,
Michael Smolkin: כי זה הכוח, כי זה כוח שפועל על חלקית. אז כוח שפועל על חלקית זה בזכות שדות חיצוניים, זה לא בזכות השדה שחלקית יוצר. עכשיו, אז השדות האלה נוצרים על ידי גופים,
Michael Smolkin: זרמים, לא יודע, מטענים, שלא קשורים לתנועה של החלקיק ולכן השדות אי טאג, בי טאג, אי ובי, לא משנה מה, הם לא תלויים במהירות.
Michael Smolkin: הם תלויים רק במקורות האלה ששמתם כדי להפעיל כוח על החלקיק. אוקיי? אז התלות היחידה בוי זה כאן, באיבר הזה, דרך המכפלה הוויקטורית הזאת. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: וצד ימין בכלל לא תלוי בוי. אז איך ייתכן שבצד שמאל, אם יש שוויון כזה, אז איך ייתכן שבצד שמאל יש תלות בוי ובצד ימין אין תלות בוי? זה יכול להיות רק אם האיבר הזה בעצם אפס.
Michael Smolkin: כי אם הוא לא אפס, אז אני על ידי שינוי של וי, אני אשנה אותו. אם הוא לא מתאפס על ידי שינוי של וי, כי חלקי, אני זורק את החלקי, כי אני יכול לזרוק אותו בכל מיני מהירויות. אז אם הוא לא יתאפס, האיבר הזה,
Michael Smolkin: אני יכול לעשות אותו מה שאני רוצה. אני אגדיל מהירות של חלקי, אשנה את הכיוון שלו, וזה פשוט הווקטור הזה ישתנה בהתאם.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? כשצד ימין לא משתנה בכלל, כי הוא תלוי רק בשדות חיצוניים ובמהירות יחסית של שתי מערכות, זה לא קשור למהירות תנועה של חלקי. אז לכן, כדי ששוויון כזה יתקיים,
Michael Smolkin: האיבר הזה חייב להתאפס. עכשיו, מתי הוא יתאפס? הוא יתאפס אם שדה מגנטי נראה אותו דבר. כלומר, לא עושה מעבר. הוא פשוט אינווריאנטי. כמו מסה, כמו מטען,
Michael Smolkin: משהו שהוא קבוע, אז יכול להיות שגם השדה המגנטי קבוע, פשוט לא משתנה במעבר ממערכת למערכת, זה עדיין לא אסון לטרנספורמציות גלילאו. אז...
Michael Smolkin: אז מכיוון שזה איבר יחיד שתלוי באבי, לכן
Michael Smolkin: הוא חייב להתאפס ואנחנו מגיעים למסקנה שבי תג שווה לבי. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: ואם בי טאג שווה לבי, אז אני פשוט מציב בי טאג שווה לבי, אני מקבל בנוסף איך שדה חשמלי עובר. אי טאג שווה לאי פלוס 1 חלקי סי, יו קרוס בי.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז שוב פעם, הגענו לחוקי טרנספורמציה האלה מתוך הנחה שטרנספורמציית גלילאו
Michael Smolkin: באמת זה ביטוי נכון לסימטריה בין מערכות אוניברסליות, אוקיי? ולכן דרשנו את זה, הנחנו את זה, וקיבלנו שככה השדות צריכים לעבור. אוקיי?
Nir Cohen: רק כדי לוודא, הנימוק היה שלא הגיוני שזה תלוי בוי? כן, הנימוק היה שאם יש איבר שתלוי, אם מצאתי כאן, כן, יש כאן משוואה,
Michael Smolkin: שדורשת שאגף ימין יהיה שווה לאגף שמאל, נכון? אז בוא, אז אני אומר נגיד שהאיבר הזה לא מתאפס, נגיד שהוא לא 0.
Michael Smolkin: אז אני מתחיל לשנות את וי, כי זה בשליטתי, אני יכול לשחרר חלקית במהירות שירותית. אז אני אתחיל לשנות את וי והגב שמאל יתחיל להשתנות. נכון?
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, אם הוא משתנה, אבל אגף ימין לא משתנה, אז איך יכול להיות שיתקיים השוויון? לא יכול להיות. לכן, מכיוון שזה האיבר היחיד שתלוי בוי, האיבר הזה, הוא חייב להתאפס. לא יכול להיות.
Nir Cohen: לא יכול להיות שהטרנספורמציה של בי תלויה במהירות של החלקיק? לא, כי טרנספורמציה של בי תלויה רק ב... הטרנספורמציה זה בין מערכות אינרציאליות, נכון?
Michael Smolkin: ולכן מה שחשוב לך לדעת זה מה המהירות היחסית של המערכות.
Michael Smolkin: כי החלקיק, יכול להיות שבכלל אין חלקיק, יש רק שדה, ואני רוצה לדעת איך שדה נראה בשתי מערכות. אוקיי? סבבה. אז לכן הטרנספורמציה לא יכולה להיות תלויה במהירות של חלקיק, אלא אך ורק במהירות של
Michael Smolkin: של יחסית של מערכות. אוקיי? ואנחנו רואים את זה במפורש בטרנספורמציית גליליה.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? תודה. השדה לא משתנה עם החלקיק עם מהירויות שונות? לא. השדה שפועל על חלקיק לא משתנה.
Michael Smolkin: אבל יהיה שדה שנוצר מהחלקיק. כן, אבל זה לא השדה שמפעיל כוח, נכון? כי הכוח מפעיל שדה חיצוני. למשל, אם יש לי שני חלקיקים, סתם אני לוקח שני חלקיקים טעונים, כן?
Michael Smolkin: סתם, קיו אחד וקיו שתיים, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: ואני שואל אותך מה, במרחק מסוים, אר, אני שואל אותך, אר גדול נגיד, אני אשאל אותך מה הכוח שפועל על חלקי קיו אחד?
Michael Smolkin: אתה תגיד אני צריך לקחת קיו אחד, להכפיל בשדה שקיו שתיים יוצא. כן, לא, בסדר, אבל אם עכשיו הוא בתנועה, זה ישרה שדות מהשינוי בזמן, השדות שזה משרה גם לא ישפיעו עליו?
Michael Smolkin: טוב, עקרונית השדה שהוא משרה יכול להפעיל כוחות על המקורות שיש בסביבה והמקורות יתחילו לנוע וכתוצאה מכך גם הכוח עליו ישתנה.
Michael Smolkin: נכון? אבל אם אני שואל בנקודת זמן נתונה, כן? עכשיו, כמובן, עכשיו,
Michael Smolkin: באופן כללי לפתור את המשוואות הדינמיות זה מסובך, אבל לא מסובך להגיד אם יש לי חלקיק, מה הכוח ברגע זה פועל עליי, מה הכוח שפועל עליי ברגע זה.
Michael Smolkin: בשביל זה אני צריך לדעת את השדות החיצוניים, לא את השדה המיידי שמייצר החלקית.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז כרגע כשאני מתייחס לשדות האלה, אי, תג, בי, תג, בי ואי, אלה שדות חיצוניים, זה לא השדות ש... בלי להתחשב בתרומה של החלקים.
Michael Smolkin: כן? כי הכוח הוא מורכב משדות חיצוניים באותו רגע. אוקיי. עכשיו,
Michael Smolkin: כשהגענו לטרנספורמציה הזאת, אז בואו נראה האם משוואות, מה קורה עם משוואות מקסוול, אם זה חוקי הטרנספורמציה, לשדות חיצוניים בלבד. אוקיי? אני לא מתכוון לשדות שהחלקיק יוצר.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז למשל, לשם פשטות, נניח שהחלקיק נע באזור איפה ש...
Michael Smolkin: נטול מקורות, כלומר המקורות מבחוץ, איפה שהוא נמצא, אין זרם או אין מטען בסביבה של החלקיק. כלומר, יש כאן תנועה של החלקיק,
Michael Smolkin: אבל המקורות, לא יודע, זרמים אולי,
Michael Smolkin: זה משהו רחוק, כן? אולי מטען קיו, זה רחוק. החלקיק, איפה שנמצא החלקיק, אין מטענים ואין זרמים, בסדר? זה לשם פשטות, כי זה לא חובה להניח את זה.
Michael Smolkin: אז אם זה המצב, ובאזור החלקיק אין שדות, אז אנחנו יודעים שחוק גאוס אומר לנו למה שווה דיברגנט של אי טאג או דיברגנט של אי, למה זה שווה? אפס. אפס, נכון? כי אין מטענים.
Michael Smolkin: הדיברגנץ הכולל הוא לא אפס כי יש שם חלקיק, אבל דיברגנץ של השדות החיצוניים זה אפס, אוקיי? כי פשוט כל המקורות מבחוץ. ואני מתייחס לשדות האלה, השדות החיצוניים, לא השדה הכולל.
Michael Smolkin: אז לפי, מצד שני, לפי גאוס, גברגנס אי,
Michael Smolkin: שווה לאפס, נכון? כן.
Michael Smolkin: אז... וזה גם צריך להיות שווה ל... ובואו נבדוק אם דיברגנס... עכשיו, נשאלת השאלה וגם חייב להתקיים,
Michael Smolkin: גיברגנס תג של אי תג שווה לאפס, כי מה זה משנה?
Michael Smolkin: אם אתם בשתי המערכות, אס ואס תג, אין שם מקורות. אז לכן זה חייב להתקיים בו זמנית. בואו נראה אם החוק הזה הוא קונסיסטנטי עם חוקי טרנספורמציה שמצאנו.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אנחנו נראה עכשיו שזה לא קונסיסטנטי, שזה לא יכול להיות שגם חוקי טרנספורמציה האלה יתקיימו וגם המשרות האלה יתקיימו. אוקיי? אז בואו נראה את זה, זה ממש...
Michael Smolkin: מהר ונסיים, בסדר? אז אני עכשיו מחשב, גיברגנס טאג, אי טאג, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: למה זה שווה? אני מציב את ה... אני כותב, זה שווה ל... מציב את הביטוי לאי טאג, אני עכשיו מציב את הביטוי הזה במקום אי טאג. אז הדיברגנס טאג של אי, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: פלוס 1 חלקי סי, דיברגן סטאג של יו קרוס בי. אוקיי? עכשיו,
Michael Smolkin: אתם זוכרים, הראינו שלחזור לפי אקסטק זה כמו לחזור לפי אקס חלקית, כי אין... לפי, עוד פעם, בגלל הקשר המיוחד בטרנספורמציות גלילאו. אז לכן,
Michael Smolkin: זה שווה לדיברגנס אי, כי לגזור לפי אקסטק זה כמו לגזור לפי אקס, הראינו את זה במפורש, וזה שווה לאפס, כן? כי דיברגנס אי מתאפס.
Michael Smolkin: אז לכן זה 0, אז נשאר לנו רק 1 חלקי סי, דיברגנץ, טאג של הדבר הזה, אז בואו נכתוב אותו כ1 חלקי סי,
Michael Smolkin: כפול גיבר גנץ, כי עוד פעם, לגזור לפי אקס טאג זה כמו לגזור לפי אקס, זה לא משנה. דוט.
Michael Smolkin: יו קרוס בי. עכשיו אני אשתמש בזהות ויקטורית שאין לי זמן כרגע להוכיח, אנחנו נראה זהויות ויקטוריות יותר מסובכות ונוכיח אותן, אבל את זה ראיתם.
Michael Smolkin: שאפשר פשוט לעשות כאן פרמוטציה ציקלית כזאת, לכתוב את זה כמינוס 1 חלקי סי יו דוט רוטור של פי.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? כאן אני משתמש בזהות ויקטורית. ועובדה שיו לא תלוי, זה קבוע, אוקיי? אז בזהות, אז צריך להשתמש בזהות ויקטורית.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אני לא אראה את זה כי פשוט אין זמן, אבל זה לא מסובך. עכשיו, לפי משוואות מקסוול, רוטור בי, רוטור בי, זה פרופורציוני,
Michael Smolkin: טוב, זה אחד חלקי, אני כרגע מקדם פרופורציה לא חשוב, כי אתם זוכרים את המשוואות מקסלו באם.קי.אס וזה בסי.ג'י, אז כרגע מקדם פרופורציה לא חשוב, אבל רוטור בי,
Michael Smolkin: הוא פרופורציוני, אם אתם זוכרים, לנגזרת לפי זמן של שדה חשמלי. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: בסדר, אז זה זה חוק אה אה אמפר מקסוול, כן? אה
Michael Smolkin: נכון? יש משוואת מקסימום. זה מתכונתי לנגזרת לפי זמן של שדה חשמלי. אז קיבלנו שזה שווה למינוס 1 חלקי סי יו דוט נגזרת לפי זמן של שדה חשמלי. אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו, המכפלה הסקלרית הזאת, יוזר בשליטה שלנו, אנחנו בוחרים, יוזר שרירותי. אז בהינתן שינוי בזמן של שדה חשמלי, אני תמיד אוכל למצוא אם כך שזה לא אפס.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? זה לא בהכרח אפס. אז לכן אתם רואים שניסינו לחשב את
Michael Smolkin: את הדיברגנס של שדה חשמלי במערכת חדשה, בהינתן חוקי טרנספורמציה שקיבלנו מתוך דרישה של חוק ניוטון,
Michael Smolkin: הוא אינווריאנטי תחת טרנספורמציות גלילאו, וקיבלנו משהו שהוא לא בהכרח אפס. זה לא בהכרח אפס. אוקיי? אז יש כאן בעיה, זה לא קונסיסטנטי כל הסיפור.
Michael Smolkin: והקונסיסטנטיות נהרסת בגלל צורה מאוד מיוחדת של מעבר בין מערכות אינרציאליות. ולכן זה צריך להיות מתוקן.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? אז נדבר על זה פעם הבאה, אנחנו קצת גלשנו כבר ונסיים. מי שרוצה לשאול שאלות, בבקשה תשאלו עכשיו.
Elam Bacil: כן, אני רואה שיש כאן. מישה, אתה אומר שהיו הזה, אנחנו יכולים לשנות אותה, אבל אנחנו לא מתייחסים ליו הזה בתור המהירות של המערכת תג שלנו?
Michael Smolkin: היו זה נכון, זה מהירות של מערכת תג, אבל יש אין סוף מערכות אוניברסליות, נכון? ואני... אם אנחנו מסתכלים בהלכה ספציפית, אז אנחנו לא יכולים תמיד, אז אנחנו לא יכולים בהכרח לשנות את יו.
Michael Smolkin: לא, לא, תראה, אני מתחיל ממערכת אס, נכון? ממערכת אס. במערכת אס יש לי, אתה אומר לי מה השדות שאתה יוצר על ידי מקורות חיצוניים, נכון?
Michael Smolkin: אז מה שנתון זה מערכת התחלתית ושדות, אי ובי, מה שאתה נותן לי, בסדר? בפרט הווקטור הזה נגזרת לפי זמן של אי, זה מה שהוא נתון, אוקיי?
Michael Smolkin: עכשיו אני שואל האם החוק גאוס, הוא נשאר להיות אפס כשאני עובר למערכת אוניברסלית אחרת כלשהי.
Michael Smolkin: נכון? מערכת אונרציאלית אחרת כלשהי, מאופיינת על ידי יו ספציפי שאני בוחר, נכון?
Michael Smolkin: אז אני מסכים איתך שיש יוים שאני אבחר ומערכת הסטארק מסוימת שאני אבחר, ששם המכפלה הסקלרית הזאת של יו ונגזרת לפי זמן של וקטור אי שנתת לי,
Michael Smolkin: יתפסו, אוקיי? אז שם על פניו אין סתירה. אבל העניין הוא שהמעבר הזה צריך להיות תקף לכל מערכת שתבחר, נכון?
Michael Smolkin: כל יו שאני אקח, כל אסתג אחר שאני אבחר לעבוד בו, לעבור אליו, נכון?
Elam Bacil: אז בגדול רק המערכות שבהן הנגזרת בזמן של אי זה אפס יתנו לנו דבר תקין. אבל אמרנו, התחלנו מזה שנגזרת בזמן של אי זה לא אפס. אתה נתת לי, זהו, אמרת זה לא אפס וזה שווה למשהו.
Michael Smolkin: אוקיי? עכשיו אני אומר בסדר, מאה אחוז, עכשיו אני רוצה לעבור למערכת אחרת ולבדוק אם חוק גאוס שם עדיין מתקיים.
Michael Smolkin: ואז אני מוצא אינסוף מערכות למעשה, ששם זה לא יתקיים. יש מספר מסוים של מערכות ששם זה יקרה, כי פשוט אם אני אקח יו אורתוגונלי לדי לגיטי של איש שנתת לי, אז שם זה יתאפס.
Michael Smolkin: אבל העניין הוא שזה צריך לעבוד לכל מערכת. אוקיי.
Michael Smolkin: אם יש שאלות, בבקשה, אתם יכולים לשאול, נשמח לענות.
Michael Smolkin: טוב, אז אם אין שאלות, אני מאחל לכם יום שקט ולימודים ככה בשקט ובנחת ותהנו ונתראה מחרתיים.
Elam Bacil: תודה מישהי, יום טוב. יום טוב. תודה רבה. להתראות. תודה רבה.